eh bien le départ a dû être donné il ne
devrait pas tarder maintenant un bon
jour venez vite il se passe quelque
chose de très intéressant aujourd'hui on
a organisé un grand cross dans l'île
vous savez ce que c'est c'est un long
parcours que l'on fait en courant dans
la campagne et celui ci consiste à 3
tours entier du jardin et du petit bois
et je vous signale que casimir s'est
inscrit c'est vrai casimir ouvrant des
côtes mais moi je trouve qu'il a
parfaitement bien fait car oui mais le
pauvre il est un peu lourd ils ont gelé
du public depuis quelques temps casimir
s'est entraînée parce que en plus de la
danse et bien fait la gymnastique
maintenant tu es moi je pense qu'il a de
grandes chances de remporter ce cross
sans que tu crois ce qui est drôle en
tout cas c'est que monsieur du snop
s'est inscrit lui aussi le sud us 9
et bien tout compte fait ça m'étonne toi
est ce que je me souviens maintenant il
avait une revanche à prendre sur
quasiment tous cas ils ne vont pas
tarder ils doivent approcher du jardin
maintenant monsieur 10 nabeul et quel
style vous asseyez pas voyons jamais
pourrez vous m'apportez un verre d'eau
c'est mon père d'auda cas où il n'y
aurait pas moins chers amis que je
participe au grand crohot de l'île aux
enfants
je sais ça monsieur 19,6 d'une très
bonne idée me dépêchais c'est une
compétition cette importance on va
certainement parler dans les journaux
une personne de ma qualité de participer
à toutes les manifestations officielles
merci beaucoup moins chers amis si vous
arrêtez sans un rêve vous allez perdre
beaucoup de temps ne vous inquiétez pas
je suis largement en tête
aucun souvenir est donc l état qu ces
séquences je veux absolument gagner
cette course
tu imagines julie lorsque l'on dira
c'est le grand casimir celui qui a gagné
le tour de l'île
je veux faire de la peine mais tu n'as
aucune chance un très bon et pourquoi
parce que si je n'étais pas dans la
course à la rigueur tour une petite
chance mais comment veux-tu me durer un
mois
écoutez tous les deux au lieu de vous
discutez voyait bien de continuer parce
que vous allez arrivé bon dernier en
effet oui tu as raison françois julie
prépare moi une glace ou jean choix pour
mon prochain passage dans les vallées
allez monsieur dix neuf mois lés
d'accord je vous quitte mes chers amis
à bientôt les casinos tikhonov aller
vite aller au françois julie aussi vous
saviez
je viens de voir passer les coureurs
derrière le petit bois ok les mirettes
extra situe à deauville m faye les
familles d après lumière nous étonnera
toujours
racontez-nous semaine vous êtes foutus
et bien monsieur du snob et lui sont en
tête
il faut vous dire que je les enfants ont
beaucoup de mal à suivre
mais l'écart se creuse et casimir et
monsieur 19 mène à tour de rôle je me
demande ce que va dire monsieur du
snapsy casimir est le premier rang des
mois un service
je veux reprendre des forces auriez-vous
quelque chose de reconstituants mais pas
indigène 1,6 en oui on le sait de
sandrine vous n'y pensez pas une banane
plutôt oui beaucoup
on a nous entendons la fin d'année tout
mais le voit la montée d'arrivée
enfin je tuerai pourra tout à me prêter
il écoute je vois mais qu'est ce que tu
veux faire des râteaux mais j'ai
remarqué que sur le chemin il y avait
des creux et des bosses
alors c'est pas pratique quand on dit
dedans parfait tu ne vas pas pouvoir
ratisser et courir en même temps et ne
recule pas j'ai un amour qui courra de
van est qui ce qui fera tout ce qu'ils
font qui dort du crois que c'est très
régulier sacrées élire mais françois ça
rend service à tout le monde voit la
mort at home et tu penses à leur
apporter
j'en étais d'accord compte sur moi à
tout à l'heure mais je suis tout ça on
peut dire que ce cross est très disputé
vous avez entendu mais pourvu que ce
soit pas quasi mieux que pourvu qu'ils
ne nous ont pas fait de mal
il me semble le reconnaître la voix tu
me situe son site ici
mais ce n'est que vous arrive-t-il amis
si vous saviez j'ai fait une
malencontreuse chute qui m'interdit de
finir la course au genou monsieur
ridiculiser quelqu'un bondir les gens si
vous avez dû vous faire très mal
titulaire d'un master amis m'appellent
ce qui est grave c'est que je ne peux
pas gagner la course
aussi je tenais celui qu'a mis au milieu
du sauna ce râteau à à tous
et oui je suis juste mon nom je prenais
le dernier virage je je je marche est
trop haute et on leur a tant qui vous
pouvez aisément et imaginer la suite
je les prends plein la figure à kelkoo
mes amis quel coût pauvre petit casimir
a dû perdre son râteau oui ben moi je
crois comprendre ce qui s'est passé et
casimir n'est sûrement pas tout à fait
innocent oh là haut pour que j'ai
quasiment 15 mois qui tombe fait gagner
la course du est peut-être tombé sur air
à toto aussi à tous pourquoi
quel toit est tombé sur un râteau disney
et ça t'étonne arrive et ça ça m'étonne
oui oui une tournoi voilà ce qu'il s'est
passé je jean tavé la dernière ligne
droite je vais pour prendre mon virage à
toute vitesse tout allait bien et je
glisse sur quelque chose et voilà je
tenais celui qui a jeté une poupe benard
c'est à glisser sur une peau de banane
ah ouais pourquoi monsieur du snob vous
n'êtes pas un gentleman
quant à toi casimir du nouveau gaming et
dire qu'il nous ferait croire tous les
deux qu'ils ne l'ont pas fait exprès au
menu le persécuté par ces pauvres petits
oignons il souffre mais ne vous
inquiétez pas la gentille et de mes
futurs
soit